[Musique]
sur l'ensemble des médiathèques du
réseau donc les 12 médiathèques du
réseau que ça soit à Villepreux Montigny
trappes on invite tout le monde à venir
jouer avec les médiathèques et avec des
on va faire des ateliers jeux vidéo jeux
de plateau jeux de société divers et
variés
les plus jeunes au plus ancien c'est
vraiment un public familial pour les
pour les gens qui débutent pour les gens
qui connaissent pour les pratiquants
pour les pour les nouveaux arrivants
c'est tout simplement de d'intégrer
aussi le jeu que ce soit le jeu de
société le jeu vidéo comme n'importe
quel support culturel que ça soit le DVD
le CD le livre
en fait le jeu à sa place au sein des
médiathèques le jeu vidéo on va avoir
tout ce qui est le
communautaire le fait de jouer ensemble
de participer ensemble de réfléchir
ensemble
d'apprendre ensemble tout ce qui est
bénéfique que ça soit dans le jeu de
plateau le jeu vidéo c'est on peut
apprendre différentes valeurs
[Musique]
le samedi on sera présent au festival du
jeu au festivieux à Villepreux le
mercredi vous retrouverez des ateliers
des ateliers jeux sur les différentes
médiathèques du réseau le vendredi soir
on aura une nuit une petite nuit du jeu
alors là c'est une petite nuit du jeu
Jeu de société au Nautilus à Villepreux
la nuit du jeu le samedi le samedi 26
novembre ou la dernière nuit du jeu
était en 2019 là on recommence ce samedi
26 novembre à la médiathèque du canal au
mumède avec le musée aussi de la ville
où tout le monde est invité entre 19h et
minuit à jouer
[Musique]